after months of denials I am confident
that I have behaved professionally
throughout I behave professionally
throughout Vision throughout profession
at all times it's all over for Dominic
Rabb the latest senior figure ousted
from Rishi sunax government amid a
scandal of his own making damaging the
Prime Minister who defended his Justice
secretary even as the bullying
allegations mounted it brings to an end
a long ministerial career we will be
able to restore control over our
immigration policy and our border
controls a prominent brexiteer he was
brought in as brexit secretary to try to
get a deal Over The Line
but stood down just a few months later
delivering a brutal blow to Theresa
May's fragile Premiership ultimately it
comes down to the political leadership
that we've got he then stood
unsuccessfully to take over the top job
before throwing his weight behind the
front runner
rewarded for his loyalty to Boris
Johnson he was made second in command
Deputy Prime Minister and foreign
secretary so senior that when the Prime
Minister was hospitalized with kovid it
was Dominic Rabb that stepped up to run
the country in his absence if there's
one thing I know about this prime
minister
he's a fighter elected in 2010 my name
is Dominic Robb unapologetically on the
right of his party I'm a tour
I don't support the Human Rights Act and
I don't believe in economic and social
rights this is looking like a very tense
exchange known for not always being in
control of his temper here he is caught
on camera backstage at a 2019 election
events
she's squaring up to a labor MP
his views on women have also drawn
criticism he said repeatedly he's not a
feminist which might explain why he
winked at Labor's Deputy leader in the
House of Commons
bullying claims have dogged him for
years but came to a head just in the
last few months as dozens of civil
servants came forward to give evidence
against him
the head of the Civil Service union says
it was long overdue I think it's clear
several servants haven't felt they could
challenge the behavior of a minister
it's clear to us this is not just about
Dominic Rabb this is a broader cultural
issue about ministers and their conduct
and a belief that they can get away with
it
a close Ally of Rishi sunak his
departure has just added to the prime
minister's problems as he now faces
questions over what he knew about his
Justice secretary's Behavior
for those who say they were bullied by
Dominic Rabb though this exit is long
overdue
Liz Bates Sky News Westminster